[Musique]
on les aime pour s'y balader courir
déjeuner et parfois même soulager une
envie pressante
les espaces verts à tour un second lieu
de vie quand les beaux jours reviennent
ce midi un agréable 24° vient caresser
la cime des arbres ici aux prébendes
dont on vient à peu près deux fois par
jour une fois le matin une fois d'après
midi parce que j'apprécie c'est celle
nature les aot les fleurs et les animaux
si on se régale à guarne des canards des
poules d'eau ça permet de prendre l'air
un petit peu entre voilà sur la pause
déjeuner et puis de profiter du beau
temps et du parc ya surtout les
préventes sait qu'on a un sol qui est
qui est assez souple ça fait du bien
pour les articulations comme celui des
prébendes tour compte une trentaine de
parcs cette richesse l'observatoire des
villes vertes la souligner dans son
dernier classement
la capitale de l'indre et loire et même
première pour son patrimoine vers 100
mètres carrés de verdure en moyenne par
habitant
c'est deux fois plus qu'au niveau
national un patrimoine qui va des
jardins aux îles de la loire en passant
par les voies végétalisée du tramway
pour l'élu verts emmanuel denis c'est
une excellente nouvelle
mais à la lecture de l'étude la ville
peut aller plus loin soixante pour cent
des gens veulent plus des espaces verts
et puis il y en a aussi 50% qui part qui
pensent que la ville de demain sera une
ville végétalisée une l'écologie ça veut
dire qu'il faut continuer il faut
continuer à investir plus on n'est pas
dans les premiers au niveau des
investissements pour les espaces verts
et puis aussi il faut continuer à
travailler sur la promotion no
nos espaces verts la bonne nouvelle dans
tout ça c'est que le vert ce n'est pas
seulement jolie vivre à proximité
réduire est de 25 % le risque de
dépression autre miracle dans le secteur
immobilier la chlorophylle se transforme
en or
jusqu'à 10000 euros de plus value si
votre logement regard d'un parc
[Musique]